OverWatch was this very successful game
Global people loved it you know nobody
anticipated how meaningful and big the
success of the game would be obviously
when it was announced that blizzard was
starting OverWatch League obviously
everyone's very excited I think it was
initially pitched as like you know NFL
for Esports yeah that's our vision for
how we're going to celebrate and reward
our players is build a league that is
like the NFL only Global profet with
three he's four players now on his own
and the Spitfire are coming through with
this one Propet finds five kills on this
Traer anybody believe that's
enough personally I was a little bit
worried because it sounded like a
logistical nightmare there was
conversations of people being like they
have to be having a hard time setting
this up so I think over time the league
lost a lot of its personality like it
just started to feel very Bland well you
know you want your team to win right
they're going to have to play What's
better from the viewing perspective it
was certainly boring to see the same
Heroes and you know on every map in
every match right I was not able to
speak publicly about owl while I worked
at twitch but you better believe that I
was the guy in every meeting going this
is stupid and you're all stupid at a
certain point I'm like what the hell do
you people want a frat boy culture that
is how Activision Blizzard is now being
described here in this new lawsuit the
danger here is YouTube go you know what
we don't want to be associated with you
because T-Mobile don't want be
associated with you Coke don't want to
be associated with you we were doing
more than fumble in the dark we were
running into walls like there was just
not it was just double shield there was
no hope in the midst of that they were
behind the scenes working on a not
sequel then sequel everything changed
kind of thing there is a community that
wants a lot of OverWatch one back and
they think a lot of the magic was lost
in 55 I think more and more people will
start to realize maybe we did have a
better there was no need for OverWatch 2
it was a cash grab marketing scam that
made them abandon the first game for
years it is kind of like a perfect storm
of that would kill an Esports League
it's insane how many bad decisions
OverWatch League made over the
years it has been something like 17
years since blizzard opened the door to
a new adventure and my friends the
waight ends right
now OverWatch
soldiers scientists adventurers when
OverWatch was released on May 24th
2016 it was something new a MOA style
hero shooter that rolled many of
Gaming's favorite elements into one
mindblowing offering it felt like sort
of return to the Saturday morning
cartoon heroes of like you know my
childhood and all that like ability
Shooters are common now but at the time
that was still something that was
relatively new and I think it wasn't
just me me I think the gaming community
in general was very excited about it
there was a palpable sense of excitement
and before long OverWatch blew up both
in terms of active player base and the
hours they spent playing the game more
than 7 million players have joined
overwatch's fight to the Future across
all three platforms 190 million hours of
the game have been played since launch
on May 24th it's so smooth it's so fresh
it's so Dynamic so responsive it's just
absolutely ridiculous on every level I
mean it is my fa game it goes without
saying this is my favorite game right
now OverWatch was designed with Esports
in mind and from the very beginning some
Regional competitions like Apex Korea
showed us just what was possible in this
new game but all of them were eventually
absorbed by blizzard in preparation for
the launch of the OverWatch League we
designed OverWatch from the ground up to
excel as a competitive game we're
looking for the top players in the world
and the team owners who will form the
OverWatch League there will be regular
schedules professional contracts free
agency Baseline minimum salaries and
benefits providing more stability for
teams and
players when it was announced that
blizzard was starting or watch League
obviously everyone was very excited
everyone thought it was going to be a
huge step forward for Esports it was
definitely seen as this moment where
Esports was going to become legit cuz
that's obviously something Esports has
struggled with for a long time and they
had this talk of like we're going to
have 50k minimum salaries and you know
the players are going to have health
care and pensions and you know it's
going to be it's going to be awesome
it's going to be this huge scale thing
these guys are getting paid to do this
the league minimum is 50 Grand a year
yes and how high does it go potentially
um so there currently isn't uh salary
cap so the scale is as good as and is to
me demand of the players now so
OverWatch league is that like Mike is
that like the NFL like is that the
today's version of the NFL only an
online yeah Megan this how they've
dialed it up I mean they're they're now
envisioning Boston playing against New
York or Boston playing against Houston
and Miami playing against Houston
players flocked to the scene chasing New
Opportunities and glory and chasing a
different kind of opportunity investors
began to pour in as well once I think
the craft group came on and officially
became the backers of the Boston
Uprising then it was kind of like oh
this is big and and I'm pretty sure that
the craft group then kind of like you
know how millionaires are they all hang
out together I guess and they were like
oh I own an Esports team you should own
an Esports team and they all got around
and started buying and paying for
Esports teams and that's when it was
kind of like oh we have like something
really really big here and it's bigger
than I think anybody thought this is
being touted as the next NFL compared to
the Premier League of the future what's
your vision for this is that for real
yeah that's our vision for how we're
going to celebrate and reward our
players is build a league that is like
the NFL only Global and it's going to
take some time but what will make it
really easy is having great Partners
like Robert Craft as far as actually
valuing the franchise like what did it
cost you to start the franchise roughly
and what do you think it's worth right
now short time later it's been reported
uh within like the $20 million range for
the first teams uh that's fairly
accurate but that's not what you would
actually pay to you think you could sell
it for a lot more than that now though
absolutely yeah for the fans though it
wasn't just about the money this was the
dawn of a new era an enormous new
offering and the people we're here for
it 113 players from 19 countries have
been signed all of them with a single
goal to be crowned the season 1 Champion
the wait is finally over it's time to
kick off the inaugural season of the
OverWatch league but it looks like the
Boston Uprising are too busy trying to
take the point that's the Widow duel one
again Philadelphia Fusion it's going to
come out at top Striker though lands a
big triple on the barrage there the
graviton helping both supports are
caught together that's what they needed
but C strikes in again Down K B com what
are you doing this is unbelievable you
kills here going in favor of the
Gladiators another hack trying to come
through from hydration onto agility we
know how devastating the hack is now his
F
like oh he's got another jump he gets KN
back bar in this is a bit bsy fish
breaks it
down fish not many widowmakers would go
for this play have a pinewood and he
just absolutely Nails it here even the
machine gun what a flick another one
beautiful I think it was initially
pitched as like you know NFL for Esports
and it seemed a little farfetched but
there was some part of you that wanted
to believe that I still remember the
moment of loading up opening night I
think it was San Francisco versus
Valiant or something 300K viewers on
Twitch and like the show is getting
started up and it just it's hard to see
that number and not be like dang this
really could be something oh the
inaugural season was just un like
unmatched the energy that it brought all
the new fans it brought in cuz it not
only brought new fans to the game but to
competitive Esports in general okay I
like this from the gladi this is this is
cute they're going to try and circle
around the Spitfire want to interrupt
this a little bit here where are you
going where are you oh The High Ground
oh this is so nasty sh's chilling in
spawn I'm going call this the merry go
around cuz it makes me laugh makes me
happy and Sh for switches to the
Widowmaker at just the right time closer
drops down and it's the day in the
shooting range for L Roberts but in
spite of all the excitement passionate
fans and Avid supporters there were
questions too blizzard was promising
more than any Esports league in history
a city-based model with home and away
games new stadiums and more
infrastructure than anything that had
come before could they really pull it
off uh you know we think with the
OverWatch league in the city-based
format which is not just unique for
Esports you know a league where Shanghai
plays Los Angeles in the regular season
is has never been done in sports either
it's it's really the first of its kind
and uh we think it it's it's going to be
something really special for for a lot
of years to come personally I was a
little bit worried because it sounded
like a logistical nightmare they were
aiming very high and being able to reach
to the goal that he wanted with
everybody just traveling considering the
logistical nightmares again as I said
earlier with the venues with
visas with preparations and so on it was
a tough dream to achieve there's
obviously a huge fan base out there that
that wants to engage with this content
live wants to go and attend events and
feel like they're a part of the global
Community celebrating the best uh gamers
in the world OverWatch is a global sport
right OverWatch is a game that's played
all over the world that's why it was
important to us to have a global League
we we have a a huge audience in the US
uh but we also have a huge audience in
China and Korea and France and Germany
and the UK uh Brazil all over the world
it was just really getting hyped up to a
point of like this has got to be bigger
and I think it even though there was
conversations after the announcement
when they got kind of quiet there was
conversations of people being like they
have to be having a hard time setting
this up let just Ally and MoneyWise and
and selling it to people but in the
early years the league blew up new and
returning fans tuned in and fell in love
with something genuinely hype is this
the secret weapon for the London
Spitfire is this the answer to their
problem's down again that Harold's
disaster generally for the fusion and C
wasn't far behind profet with three he's
killed four players now on his own and
the Spitfire are coming through with
this one profit five kills on this TR
and you believe that's enough but
OverWatch as a game was struggling more
and more with balance and meta issues
and slowly but surely souring the fan
base on the league and a particularly
notorious offender was goats as we saw
so season 2 come around and uh you know
players starting to really orbit around
a very safe way to play we had uh the
goats meta spawn which was the
composition that featured no DPS players
I think we're just going to focus focus
on Basics you know just play goats and
this is just still the standoff between
both of these teams but London with that
sound barrier looking to end this
fight such sustain there's no no one is
dying anywhere on this bird rings got
another grab the second end of the fight
going to catch several again followup
still not quite there Transcendence able
to keep him alive and now finally
someone dies and happens to be profit
and that's goats in a nutshell from the
viewing perspective it was certainly
boring to see the same Heroes you know
on every map in every match right you
know I I do feel like that's something
that could have been dealt with a lot
sooner than it was you know we we needed
a patch and it didn't come for whatever
reason we do see the Outlaws are going
to pull out D's Tracer this has been
some some of the things that Outlaw fans
were waiting for is a good Tracer player
on Houston it's Jake on the far this
combo's worked well for them before but
as soon as they see the defensive setup
they will just simply swap it away
crucial time lost Here For the Outlaws
just letting the fans give their uh the
fans here in the studio give their
opinion well you know you want your team
to win right they're going to have to
play what's meta chat I cannot imagine
what it's like to be a pro player right
now chat chat I want you to think of
this okay people and pro players scrim
this met up probably 6 to8 hours a day
and I think that after a while we
realized that was maybe not really
conducive to uh exciting gameplay or at
least a varied you know array of
different gameplay styles so there was
definitely a dark patch in season 2
where VPS were not necessary goats
wasn't the only thing the community
found repetitive though as the OverWatch
League became more and more
commercialized some players and teams
began to feel redundant that Personal
Touch the magic that Drew in so many
people at the start was beginning to
fade so I think over time the league
lost a lot of its personality like it
just started to feel very Bland and you
know like there was so many teams as
well like 20 teams and it was just like
do I care about team 18 playing Team 17
no not really and even again like I said
there wasn't much distinguish that match
from any other match more and more
people began to feel that The Fan
Experience just wasn't the same and
negative sentiments began to spread
throughout the league some people
started to question the future of the
whole Enterprise I've seen people say
well goats is dead um and now it's just
double sniper and that's going to be
terrible or oh now everybody's just
going to play McCree and at a certain
point I'm
like what the hell do you people want so
in other words you don't want them to
eat all the ults in the game like Diva
no okay makes sense there are these
moments of regret that you have as a a
game developer and perhaps eating
everybody's ult is one of those but
there was a big change on the horizon
for the OverWatch League just not one
that any of the fans wanted the decision
decision to take the League's broadcasts
from twitch to YouTube was instantly
controversial especially after reports
that they left a $90 million deal behind
the twitch deal collapses and then what
blizzard do is a deal with YouTube to
put everything exclusively on YouTube
which caused a ton of problems cuz
really you want your ort on Twitch if
I'm totally honest I was not able to
speak publicly about owl while I worked
at twitch for obvious reasons but you
better believe that I was the guy in
everying meeting going this is stupid
and you're all stupid and it did not
feel good I'll tell you why it didn't
feel good because that League cost a lot
ofing money and a year later 11 of mying
staff was laid off OverWatch had the
highest average minute audience of any
channel on Twitch what we've learned is
a couple of things one is you need to go
for the biggest audience right um and if
we were to do a doover I would say let's
not go to YouTube or go exclusive just
yet dude there's a there's also a big
chance that the OS league is just going
to die
completely like that's a that's a big
change guys we've been watching the
Corona virus for weeks now uh continuing
to see the market action trade around
the updates we get but the Corona virus
is also hitting Esports as popular
gaming leagues like Activision blizzards
OverWatch league and 10-cent Holdings
Riot games because it seems the Corona
virus has spread to South Korea and more
countries as well the soul Dynasty home
stands will be cancelled and when they
got word of the virus spreading they had
to speedrun packing all of their stuff
in order to make a last minute flight
back this is scary stuff man Co Strunk
at the worst possible time for OverWatch
League we were just moving into what was
the long-term dream of the OverWatch
League was to have hestands to really
make this city-based model work there's
more to come after the
break what's that I think yep it's the
invoy Excel take on the London Spitfire
if that had been able to happen that
would have been magical fore OverWatch
league and it could have been an
incredibly different future from what
we're seeing now because that was the
Grand Vision there were a lot of changes
with the matches moving online what was
the biggest takeaway for you guys uh in
terms of adjusting to these new
situations obviously being our own rooms
you know we're on team speak together uh
so it's not really as as Humane like I
would say despite some arguments that Co
actually extended the owl's lifespan
ultimately it put the big BG most
interesting thing about the league on
the back burner indefinitely and that
was devastating eventually the pandemic
began to ease off maybe that could have
been a chance to see the league return
to its original plans but instead
Activision Blizzard had to deal with
another sort of illness the kind that
rots companies from the
inside a frat boy culture that is how
Activision Blizzard is now being
described here in this new lawsuit filed
by the California Department Department
of Fair Employment and housing the
agency alleges that male employees play
video games during the workday while
delegating responsibilities to female
employees engage in sexual banter and
joke openly about rape among other
things so they're making the girls do
all the work while they talk about rape
and harassing them I saw a lot of people
just want to boycott the league when
that news started coming out all the
internal blizzard struggles it really
just did more damage and the sponsorship
end as well we had all these different
sponsors and now poof it's all gone the
danger here is YouTube go you know what
we don't want to be associated with you
because T-Mobile don't want to be
associated with you Coke don't want to
be associated with you Brands like that
were not putting money in anymore and of
course that's going to hurt you know the
bottom line if you've got teams all
around the world and you're spending
money to bring DJ khed to perform at
your finals and sponsors are pulling out
because of the news that's breaking that
your company might have been like an
absolutely horrific work place for women
to be in I don't understand how you
could then keep an expensive Esports
League up while that's going on for a
long time I think they've just been a
horrible company they have not been that
Golden Age blizzard people like to
pretend that they still are it is a
company that is so far out of touch and
so corrupt that it's gross it it was a
bummer it was a bummer to see you know
that happen to League cuz you know as
far as I'm aware you know that part of
the whole Machinery at blizzard
Activision didn't really deserve that
hit you know so they certainly felt the
effects right the sponsors leaving
through you know no fault of their own
so I think they were they sort of ended
up being kind of like secondary victims
to the whole situation right where you
know they were also very negatively
affected by all this happening and
what's even perhaps more sad to
acknowledge is that a lot of devs that
you might find to be heroes I find to be
heroes of mine may have known about this
all along and maybe even participated in
it it's horrible and uh
even as public outrage over the
harassment suit and internal demons
threatened to tear blizzard apart
players were getting fed up with the
lack of meaningful changes worse yet
blizzard seemed to be focusing on
OverWatch 2 instead of looking for ways
to improve the original game theyo
moving over to the diva just going to be
duplicating that up but Jackson now
finally unleashing that support and
ultimate he was saving it's more than
enough to try and clear them away and
violet falling means there's going to be
a lack of heals that Sou as well maybe
this is going to be a hot take I think
this is the worst thing to happen
to OverWatch this is up it is not
fun it is not skill it ising it
is dog this is so bad I don't know
cuz people are going to say oh what
about Brig release or what about uh
goats or no this is so bad there was no
lights in that tunnel like that that
tunnel was Pitch Black we were doing
more than fumbling in the dark we were
running into walls like there was just
not it was just double shield there was
no hope there was no communication zero
nothing at all and once again blizzard
seemed fixated on the wrong problems
OverWatch has always been played with
two teams of six players OverWatch 2
will be played with two teams of five
players holy I think it's going to
suck in the long term for off tank
players because inevitably it will mean
that we're probably going to see some
tank players getting shafted and and
going to be losing their jobs in some
capacity I would say it looks better
than it did before but there's a longing
way to go there's no way that this is
the work that had been done in like 2
years there's just no way a lot of
people were just kind of frustrated in
losing out on what we had in OverWatch
one one of the biggest draws that they
had for the game was the fact that it
was a 6v6 Arena shooter not a 5v5 like
every other you know game out there has
is is kind of been so I think there's a
lot of disgruntled people losing out on
things like that not wanting some of
their favorite characters to be reworked
cuz you know you might have to learn a
completely different play style
depending on what hero you like to play
you're literally cutting an entire roll
it's like baseball being like now we
don't have a short stop all of a sudden
they cut a roll out and teams have to
adjust there is a community that wants a
lot of OverWatch fun back and they think
a lot of the magic was lost in 55
whether or not that can be fixed with
tanks being updated or supports being
nerfed we'll see we'll see through the
next year like if if it does if it
doesn't get better the next year like I
think more people will start to realize
like maybe we did have a better and even
when OverWatch 2 did come out the
promised and highly anticipated PVE mode
never materialized at all the player
base started to spiral with everything
we've learned about what it takes to
operate this game at the level that you
deserve it's clear that we can't deliver
on that original vision for PVE that was
shown in 2019 there was no need for
OverWatch 2 it was a cash grab marketing
scam that made them abandon the first
game for years and just try to cash grab
skins an upgraded shop anybody who tries
to tell you that this has not been the
biggest manipulation in scam in
multiplayer gaming history is lying
through their teeth crisis after crisis
had eroded the foundation of the
OverWatch League a lethal combination of
unrealized potential unfulfilled
promises and unrelenting monetary issues
threatened to Snuff out what was
supposed to be the most important thing
Esports has ever done as reports of mass
layoffs on the Esports side began to
surface it was time to admit that the
death of the OverWatch League was no
longer an if but rather a win more so
than anything else the legacy of the
league is going to be uh as sad as it
may be a legacy of failure of doing as
an Americans say biting off more than
you can chew really um maybe going a
little bit Too Big Without Really having
the framework the infrastructure the
management I mean I've heard so many
horror stories about OverWatch leag
management you know whether it's the
orgs or the teams and I think that like
obviously it's it's a bit of a caution
that you know you need to make sure that
you have the foundation the fans support
uh the teams the leadership that you
need to be able to run something this
big it doesn't help that the league was
only in place for 2 years before a
global pandemic happened like it doesn't
help that in the midst of that they were
behind the scenes working on a not
sequel then sequel everything changed
kind of thing you know it is kind of
like a perfect storm of that would
kill an Esports League now it didn't
seem as if blizzard was ready to
announce its plans for OverWatch Esports
at or around the 2023 Toronto finals but
the writing was on the wall this was
going to be the League's last Harrah
it's probably better for the health of
overw Esports and probably better for
the health the players that it's dying
just because the the format in its own
it's just not self-sustainable it was
inevitable at some point so rather than
sooner than rather than later I think
it's probably a lesson for people in
terms of the ambition behind like what
ESP Sports is I think that like people
presumably expected OverWatch League to
become like a multi-million like sports
rival I think it just can't hit the
heights that maybe we expected for and I
think probably when you start to put in
binds of like 20 30 million the return
investment was going to be difficult
watch leag has been a very ambitious
project from day one and a decent part
of that ambition has been fulfilled a
lot of that has been left on the table
and you know in an alternate timeline we
can only imagine what that would have
looked like I think we watch leag will
go down as a it could have been amazing
ended up being underwhelming because you
know the idea was great that there
should be a proper league for Esports
and a proper managed ecosystem for pro
players where they feel job security
where they feel safety where they can
kind of grow without fear of well if we
don't win this tournament we we're out
of a job I think unfortunately the
people people are going to look at the
OverWatch league as an example of what
not to do and it's hard not to look at
it that way from how the league has went
I had such high expectations and high
hopes for this when I when I started I
mean I moved halfway across the world
for it I completely changed my career
for OverWatch watch um you know I really
believed in it given everything that's
happened with the league you know team's
already pulling out right you know I
mean it's probably better if OverWatch
League goes away after this finals um
and that's I want to be clear that
that's not saying OverWatch Esports
should go away I think OverWatch Esports
can go through kind of a you know a
resurrection almost right where it's
like now we're going to be able to start
building things again in in sort of a
more Grassroots genuine Esports way the
over watch League gave orgs the option
to vote on whether or not they wanted to
continue playing in the current system
or cut their losses take a payout and
withdraw they all chose the ladder
nailing shut the OverWatch League's
coffin for good they are all amazing
individuals and really did deserve
better um unfortunately though the power
ends at B that were much stronger than
them and I think OverWatch could have
been amazing in that department but they
really f fumbled the bag and they didn't
fumble it once they fumbled it and then
they fumbled it again it's insane how
many bad decisions OverWatch League made
over the years the biggest swing taken
in the history of Esports turned out to
be a failure OverWatch Esports will of
course persevere but the gargantuan
ambitious OverWatch League That was
supposed to change Esports as we know it
is no more with this game and with its
Esports you just see massive potential
but then you just see failure to deliver
and it's always from upper management
positions and it's always dropping
people who are on the ground actually
doing the good work but there was
definitely interest and this is what
makes it sad I think with OverWatch
League the community remains as
passionate as it's ever been the fans
that stuck with OverWatch through thick
and thin are still here cheering for
what's coming next the hype that it was
generating at the start the overall
interest was so crazy and I think with
this being such a unique model there was
so much potential for it to really
thrive obviously in the end it was too
overly ambitious and people are going to
look back at that we knew what this
league could have been we saw it in the
first season even the second for a
little bit it could have been something
amazing and like there were a lot of
special moments it really could have
blown the Esports scene away and be
something legendary that people would
remember forever despite the
disappointment I might feel in some
aspects it's always good to remember
that it delivered some special memories
and that a lot of these players aren't
to blame for any of this they worked
their hearts off for this and it was
amazing honestly even as it goes away I
think we can all kind of cherish these
memories I think it's an ort that kind
of captured some special things that no
other esport would be able to
[Music]
do